neighbors turned out by the hundreds
last night for an emotional vigil to
remember a mother and two young girls in
Frederick Colorado the vigil was just
days after Christopher Watts reportedly
confessed to killing his wife it's
expected he'll be charged next week
Shannon Watts who was 15 weeks pregnant
and their two young daughters Bella and
Celeste
Omar Villafranca has more in the latest
court motions filed Chris Watson's
attorney is asking for DNA samples to be
taken from the two girls what the
defense wants to do with the samples is
not known the paperwork also notes that
the children were found in an oil tank
filled with crude oil and had been there
for several days mr. Watts why did you
kill your wife and two children the 33
year old is being held in a Colorado
jail after he reportedly confessed to
killing his pregnant wife Shannon and
their two daughters three year old
Celeste and four-year-old Bella their
bodies were discovered on Thursday on
the property of one of his work sites
it's like a nightmare that I just can't
wake up from
earlier this week Watts told reporters
he had no idea where his family could be
he even pleaded for their safe return
it's not something I could ever ever
fathom what happened in my lifetime
Shannon's brother lashed out at Watts on
Facebook I just want 30 seconds alone
with that heartless psychopath may Satan
have mercy on his soul
Kelly trippy is a neighbor we when you
got the news Wednesday and I won't went
through your mind shock you don't know
someone at all until you find out that
they have done something so evil she is
still trying to make sense of what
seemed like a perfect marriage and home
life outside of the home the memorial
continues to grow for the family the
defense also left the house after
collecting evidence for their own case
as for Watts he's expected to be
formally charged on Monday for CBS this
morning Saturday Omar Villafranca
Frederick Colorado incredibly disturbing
case